My name is Chris Adams.
I'm a globe maker
and I've been making globes
for the best part of fourteen years now.
To make a globe you start off with a mould
and you make a very wet mix of plaster
and swirl it around to make sure there's a uniform coverage of plaster in the mould.
When that is dry, you then make a second mix, a wet mix
and pour that in
and re-enforce it with paper.
They used to use card or various other materials but I've found paper is the best
it's lightweight and still retains its strength.
When that is dry, it's blown out of the mould
and the two halves are joined together.
It's sanded down, rubbed down until they're very smooth
and given a final coat of shellac to
strengthen it and to seal it.
At this stage the map will be applied.
They're called gores, there are usually
twelve gores that go around a globe.
They are stretched onto the globe ensuring
all lines match up so there's no
overlaps there's no under laps. Everything
should match up nicely.
One of the things you have to bear in mind when applying a gore is the fact that the paper will stretch.
It's designed to stretch two
percent in one direction.
It has to be printed with that in mind, you have to reduce the the artwork two percent to allow for the stretch.
I've been doing it for so long that it's quite easy for me gores
and make the lines match up and make sure they make sure the paper behaves as I want it to.
It's a skill that I've leaned and picked up, so I'd like to think I'm quite good these days.
Once the gores have been applied they are given a seal
and then hand coloured, hand tinted and unusually given an age afterwards to make the globes look old.
I prefer to think of it as giving them a head start in the ageing process.
I try to remain true to the materials and methods of traditional globe making.
Obviously, I improve where I can.
A lot of the materials they used traditionally were animal based, which I like to move away from if I can.
The plaster I use now is not dissimilar to
the plaster that they used but it's far
stronger and harder wearing.
So it's little things that they would have incorporated as well, if they have the chance.
Globes were traditionally educational which perhaps isn't the case these days
but I think a globe still has a role to play.
It's nice to have something tangible in your hands to see exactly where we are in the world, where we'd like to go.
You can spin a globe and see what's on the other side of it from where you are,
which you can't necessarily do from a monitor or a book